foreign
you're a neuropsychopharmacologist
specializing in the research of drugs
that affect the brain and conditions
such as anxiety yeah addiction and sleep
the chairman of drug science a
non-profit founded in 2010 providing an
evidence-based information on drugs
sound right sound good sounds perfect
your new book is on cannabis called
cannabis seeing through the smoke why
are you choosing to write about cannabis
and why now in particular
well cannabis is a very interesting drug
and it's become particularly pertinent
in the last couple of years in Britain
because we have seen
it turned into a medicine so three years
ago the government said oh yeah we got
it wrong it actually is a medicine and
they allow doctors to prescribe but
sadly very few doctors on the NHS are
prescribing in fact one of the things my
charity drug science has done is is set
up a system an initiative which allows
people to access medical cannabis
without going through the NHS at the
same price they pay if they're doing it
in the black market
so we're in a bit of a Crossroads we've
got it as a medicine but doctors aren't
using it why is that because they don't
know about it they don't understand it
and I thought it was timely then to
write a book it kind of laid out the
truth about cannabis about THC about tea
cannabidiol and also about medical
cannabis The herbal plant products as
well which are actually probably the
most interesting of all the uh the
Cannabis products could you talk a bit
more about the benefits of cannabis when
used as medicine when used as a drug
that you're trying to inform people
about I mean cannabis is probably the
world's oldest medicine we've got
evidence of it being used in China four
thousand years ago one of the most
interesting things I've discovered about
medical cannabis is that the Chinese
character for anesthesia is the same as
for cannabis and those characters have
been around for about six thousand years
so it's a very old medicine in fact it
was a medicine in Britain until 1971.
it was used by Queen Victoria to deal
with Pains of charred birth and and
period pains and it would disappeared in
1971 because eventually the British
government gave in to the Americans the
Americans removed it as a medicine 1934
when they made out when alcohol was made
legal again in America the the feds who
were attacking the uh the underground uh
the alcohol Market were then encouraged
to switch to attack cannabis and they
basically said cannabis was very
dangerous drug and it had to be banned
and the Americans took it out of their
medicine in 1934 and we held on in
Britain you know for quite a few years
but in 1971 we conceded and we we've
stopped it being a medicine
despite the vast amount of evidence of
it being used before and of course
what's resurrected it is the fact that
there are mothers particularly or sorry
parents of children with severe epilepsy
whose epilepsy hasn't responded to any
other treatment
and they've learned that medical
cannabis can help them but they've had
to go overseas to get it they've had to
go to Canada to
to the states or to Holland and often
have spent years living there in order
to access this medicine for their
children
and about a year ago we started
collecting a group we've got 21 of these
children and we can show
overwhelming evidence that medical
cannabis the horrible stuff that with
all the Entourage effect
transforming the lives of these children
but still only two of them are getting
it on the NHS the rest are having to get
it privately so we're now in a situation
where we I think cannabis is likely to
be one of the great medical Innovations
in the next 20 30 years doctors aren't
using it so doctors aren't fulfilling
the you know the potential of the
medicine is there a difference in age or
background uh or training between the
doctors who do listen the argument's in
favor of cannabis and those who don't
can you like separate those out
So currently I'm trying to understand
why doctors won't prescribe and there
are there's a structural problem in that
when cannabis was made in medicine three
years ago the only people allowed to
prescribe were specialists
no Specialists there are a couple of
things that characterize Specialists the
first is they're very special
and they see themselves as very special
people and they've often done a lot of
research
and if and none of them would have
researched cannabis so they're kind of
top of the medical pyramid but they only
do what they know and that's how they
maintain their sort of
I don't know the status of being a
specialist and this the syndromes and
the the some of the symptoms that
medical cannabis is good for are largely
things like pain and anxiety and uh and
spasms Etc which aren't the things that
Specialists actually are interested in
what we should be doing is allowing GPS
to prescribe medical cannabis so we
could they could get people off all the
other drugs they're using for those
conditions and put them on something
that's likely to be both safer and more
effective so we've we've basically given
it to the wrong group of doctors in
terms of the age yes what I'm finding
now that young doctors who are coming
into medicine are thinking they want
they're more open-minded because they
haven't been telling the world how
dangerous cannabis is but from the ones
are over about 35 onwards they've
they're so used to telling and saying
that cannabis is a dangerous drug that
causes dependence it causes
schizophrenia it's very hard to get them
to admit they were wrong and and change
their prescribing what are those myths
about the dangers of cannabis that
um you think are most harmful you know
and how do you dispel them
so when cannabis was made illegal
a campaign was set up in the states and
we certainly followed suit
to try to justify it's being banned
and initially the campaign was a very
racist one it was
cannabis was actually a Mexican drug and
it was renamed marijuana and back then
in the 30s the America the US government
and the the um the CIA and the and the
you know the the feds were
telling everyone how dangerous this drug
is the Mexicans were using this drug
coming in and destroying American
culture
and I didn't really have much traction
in Britain but in the 1950s when we
started to get a growing number of
people from the um the Caribbean
afro-caribbeans here they started using
cannabis and so that's sort of the kind
of slightly racist tint to sort of fear
that these people are using something
which isn't quite British it's not
alcohol started to take root and people
started to try to find arguments it was
a cultural problem but I didn't really
carry much weight but then people
started looking at this question of
schizophrenia
and so it was a kind of British
invention that um cannabis might cause
schizophrenia now it probably doesn't
and certainly in those days it
definitely didn't but what they did was
that that was a sufficient
the powerful argument for the government
to really justify clamping down very
hard on people using cannabis and of
course what happened then and this is
this is a terrible sort of moral story
really as predicted if you clamp down on
something that's not very harmful like
traditional herbal cannabis being
imported from Morocco or from the
Lebanon what happened we started to grow
our own so we started to do hydroponic
24-hour ultraviolet light growing you
know Vietnamese gangs and what they grew
was a much stronger form of cannabis
called skunk
and and skunk has there are two big
problems with skunk the first is it is
more likely to cause psychosis because
it doesn't contain the protective
element herbal cannabis is a combination
of cannabidiol and THC and THC can make
you high but also make you slightly
paranoid and cannabidiol opposes that
but when you grow plants to have very
strong THC the cannabis oil doesn't
can't do both so it just makes THC so
you end up basically getting the
unbalanced mixture in skunk
and that seems to have more it certainly
has more risk of dependence and it
almost certainly has more risk of
causing psychosis so in an attempt to
get rid of cannabis by really
criminalizing the Youth of the use of
traditional cannabis we've actually
driven the market to produce a much more
harmful form
and then of course it got worse it got
worse when we started testing prisoners
when using cannabis and then the
prisoners switched to spice to these
synthetic cannabinoids which which
aren't detectable with the same um
chemistry as cannabis was detected and
are way more toxic so all our attempts
to prohibit cannabis have actually just
led to greater and greater harms from
what has replaced it the the myths that
uh were created to justify the policy
decision came to exacerbate the negative
consequences of the
doctor it was a two year long research
project for this with over 20 000
patients is that so I'll talk about this
yeah yeah if you talk about that yeah
three years ago when the chief medical
officers said yes it can be a medicine
we thought great let's you know we can
dog scientists can go and do something
else you know like try to get
psychedelics legalized or made of
medicine and after a few months we
realized that nothing was happening with
medical cannabis and half are we so we
convened a conference and we started
talking to to the patients and the
doctors and the regulators and we
realized that actually things weren't
going to happen because there was such
resistance from the NHS
from the doctors and also from the
pharmacists
because in the realities in the NHS you
cannot prescribe me a new drug like
medical cannabis would be without
essentially if the pharmacists control
it they control the budget they make the
decision
and so we thought well let's
let's monitor the situation and so we
started essentially collecting
information on who was getting
prescribed and it became obvious after a
few more months that no one was getting
prescribed and then there was a survey
done in 2019 which showed that about a
million people over probably 1.4 million
people in Britain are using medical
cannabis each day
but they're getting it from the illegal
market and there are huge problems there
obviously I mean you don't know what
you're getting for one one week you
might be getting 15 THC the next week
you might be getting 12. almost anything
you get won't have the Cannabis dial in
which is one of the key elements of
medical cannabis
and so we thought well what can we do to
sort of solve this problem if the NHS
won't solve it so we set up what was
called 2021 project 2021 and we did it
with one of the Charities that represent
people who are taking medical cannabis
illegally and and they had 20 000
members
and so we thought wouldn't it be
wonderful if in a couple of years we
could get all those 20 000 people
from the black market into the uh
approved market and what we did was
essentially set up a process whereby
they could all access medical cannabis
at the same price
as they're paying on the black market
which is about 150 pounds a month
and we were successful in doing that by
bringing together a whole series of
different medical cannabis producers
from different countries and they've all
essentially brought medical cannabis to
Britain at that price which is a
non-profit level you know it's a sort of
base price for them and now already
we've got 1500 people going through the
uh the initiative
but the really clever thing about it
and the why it's in a major Advance is
when it's not just about getting people
medicine but it's about monitoring
how they do
and particularly monitoring anything
that goes wrong so so we're rating
whether they get dependent we're rating
if they go psychology because we want to
show and we think we will that if you
use cannabis in a medical setting with
the right balance of cannabidiol and THC
it not only works and helps people deal
with their symptoms but doesn't cause
the problems that have been projected
onto cannabis by the The Regulators and
by politicians you've
sad or written that the West is
in UK as well one of very few societies
that has an open mind towards
psychedelics these psychedelics
um you've made it your life's work to
start to break down those barriers do
you sometimes feel like you're not
making arguments about psychedelics but
it's more about the nature of the
society you're working and what does it
say about Britain or the West that
people have been for the last 50 years
so close-minded or shut off to these
sorts of arguments
I started working for the government as
a drugs advisor in
1994 when we had a few deaths from MDMA
and that committee was actually quite an
effective committee because we basically
recommended free water in all venues
which still happens today the fact you
can always get tap water in pubs or
restaurants was part of the process that
we put through to reduce the harms of
MDMA and we also recommended chill out
rooms and that was an amazing public
harm a message because virtually no
deaths from MDMA in the in the
subsequent itself 20 30 years except
when people tried to stop it and various
novel forms such as PMA which have come
along but MDMA itself you can deal with
the harms of MDMA sensibly by allowing
people to get it in a situation where
they can be protected and as a result of
that I was asked to advise several
government committees on how we should
deal with other drugs and I was full of
enthusiasm you know there was a rational
response to MDMA so let's I assume
there'd be a rational response to other
drugs but I when I started looking at it
I realized that actually the drugs which
had already been made illegal you could
not have a rational discussion about
and why is that that is because if you
try to change the the legal status of a
drug that is illegal the newspapers the
right-wing press go into go insane
and then of course the most classic
example of that was when
um we were eventually allowed to
seriously discuss the legal status of
cannabis cannabis until
2004 some forms of cannabis were Class A
alongside
crystal meth and crack cocaine and some
forms of cannabis were a Class B
and after quite a detailed assessment
The Advisory Council which I was on at
the time said they should all be Class C
and the newspapers went insane and they
they desperately tried to stop that
happening but that
blanket was a home secretary at the time
and he he pushed that through because he
realized that that was what the science
said
but subsequently the media backlash
terrified Blair and then Brown and the
subsequently Cameron and May and since
then governments have always been
absolutely terrified of loosening
I would say be more rational about the
classification of any drug and
eventually cannabis got regraded and
that's how I got sacked for proposing
that and subsequently now we've been
pushing more and more drugs into the
legal category in fact under Theresa may
be brought in this completely bizarre
piece of legislation which says anything
apart from alcohol that affects your
brain it's actually illegal even if even
if it's never been invented so so it's
the drugs drug laws are they have they
have two roles they fulfill the need of
many aspects of the media to to find
someone to hate and something to hate
and get banned and then they serve a
kind of political purpose that
politicians can pretend they're doing
something they can make a law even
though the law actually is probably
going to do more harm than good it's
interesting so on the one hand your
career your research your roles in
government and within institutions has
done so much to educate and Advance
Arguments for these psychedelics
narcotics but on the other hand you've
lived through a political terrain where
you can have a law passed a couple of
years ago by conservative government
that would make illegal anything that is
an alcohol like how do you reconcile
that are you happy with your like life's
work or do you think like when are you
going to sit back and be you know
well
it is it is paradoxical isn't it
we're confronted with this bizarre
continued Banning of things only last
week at home pretty Patel New Home
Secretary said if the acmd were minded
to make nitrous oxide illegal she would
put the full force of the law to impose
you know sanctions against people who
use weapons I mean what an absurd thing
to say for you know to give people
criminal records for doing something and
so inhaling a balloon which is way less
harmful than getting drunk but on the
other side and that and this is where I
I guess I can take some credit on the
other side by pushing and pushing the
medical value
of medical cannabis and their
psychedelics and MDMA we've at last
begun at least to have a there is an
alternative dialogue so when I started
doing you know advising the government
in 20 odd years ago
you couldn't really say there was these
drugs had a benefit even though you knew
if you said it you would get vilified
now people say yeah of course you know
now that everyone accepts they have a
benefit and the question now is what's
the nature of the regulation that will
allow them to be used beneficially but
still protect the poor innocent youth
reviews how is your research along with
the findings you've made
impacted you as a person
so I've been fighting a battle for 30
years to bring a much more rational
approach to drugs to assessing the harms
of drugs but also to assessing the
benefits of drugs
and uh
I don't I mean I think in a way I've
been kind of quite fortunate because I
was put in the position
where I where what I said actually was
listened to they might not have liked
what I said
but at least I did have a role
responsibility as the drugs are to
advise government on drugs so I think
it was perhaps inevitable I was going to
be sacked but the sacking in itself
stressful it was a pretty tough year but
in reality what it did was it actually
made the debate happen
and also I was I discovered
they were you know most well sorry not
most but a lot of the scientific
communities behind me they wouldn't come
out and say so but they'd say it
privately so I I knew I was you know a
bit of a flag bearer for them and uh and
that that was actually really in the end
that was really quite satisfying and I
think I could look back on the last 30
years and say well you know we've
actually for patients we've moved the
field forward a lot we do have medical
cannabis if people want to use it and
and some private doctors do and I'm
pretty sure we will have medical
cytocybin and we will have medical MDMA
in the next few years
and I you know I think I've made a
significant contribution to both these
[Music]